I believe the world has set a glass
ceiling on the problem of extreme
poverty most organizations and
governments are really trying to fight
to see you then get closest to that
glass ceiling but very very few believe
we can actually break through the glass
ceiling I think to do that it's going to
take a very different perspective it
will take people willing to challenge
assumptions in the aid industry that
have been around for decades it's gonna
take people who can think innovatively
coming from different backgrounds not
necessarily from International
Development backgrounds not necessarily
from the Peace Corps and and Vala many
economics backgrounds that those kind of
things but from high tech and from the
military and from government and from
business you know like people who can
have a different way of thinking one of
the things that I think we need to
leverage in the social sector much more
are solid effective business practices
and business principles I think we need
to hold organizations accountable just
as investors hold private-sector
for-profit companies accountable I think
we need a more rigorous measurement
system you know in the private sector we
have financial statements and the social
sector we have a lot of different things
that are not standard and that nobody
you know an investor in the social
sector has no standardized yardstick
where they can measure option a vs.
option being an investment we need that
kind of system we need more rigorous
measurement but until we have that we
need companies not organisations we need
companies who will run those companies
as a business not as a charity you know
we need to leverage best business
practices because there's a limited
amount of capital available for this
work so we need to take that capital and
stretch it as far as possible and be as
efficient as we can we need the best
minds in the world not in the private
sector we need it in the social sector
right so we need to be able to take the
best people and throw them at the the
toughest problem we have today
I think extreme poverty is the greatest
crisis of our time and I think it's
worthy of the greatest minds of our time